それでは研究倫理かける生成AIの動画を始めていこうと思います。ここまでですね、生成AIの仕組みや限界について話してきました。そして、研究倫理ということで、誠実さという土台について考えてきました。
それではですね、その知識をもとに、実際の研究活動とAIの関係をどう考えるのかという話に入っていこうと思います。
ここからグッとですね、皆さんの聞きたいテーマに入っていくのかなと思うので、楽しくやっていきましょう。
サブテーマにある通りですね、合言葉は2つです。
1つ目はですね、投稿先のポリシーを確認しましょうということ。
それから研究の段階にもとに判断しましょうということです。
それではやっていきましょう。
まずですね、ちょっとこの4つの軸というものを、すごい単純なものですけど、見ていただければと思います。
研究のライフサイクルというところで、4つのステージがあります。
研究の実施ですよね。
まずはどんな論文があって、それからコードを作って、データを取得して、分析して、文献検索などと書いてますけど、中身を作っていく段階ですよね。
それから原稿作成というのもあります。
倉庫を作ったり、あるいは図表を作ったりとか、原稿に仕上げていく段階です。
その次に、砂読があります。
出てきた原稿をですね、評価する側に渡して読んでもらう。
あるいは皆様が評価する側になるというパターンです。
その後、砂読への対応を変えているところで、受け取った砂読に応答して、改定する段階というのがあったりします。
同じAIを使うといってもですね、それぞれの段階によって、何ができるか、あるいは何が安全と考えられているかというのが全く変わります。
なのでですね、それぞれの段階で、皆様が今自身がどこの範囲をやっているのかということを基にですね、考えていただければと思います。
今回のスライドの中でですね、最も重要になるというか、参照にしているのがこちらのスライドでございます。
これですね、サイエンスジャーナルガイドライン for AIUSAGEと書いていますけれども、
サイエンスという有名な雑誌がありますよね。
科学、理学系ではトップジャーナルなわけでございます。
その中でですね、例えば研究の実行中、研究の準備中、
研究というか、マニセフトの準備中、それから原稿をレビューしている間、
砂読中、それからその砂読に応える間というところでですね、分かれていますので、
それに従ってさっきのものというのを作っていたわけでございます。
さっきのですね、サイエンスジャーナルガイドラインをよく見てほしいんですけれども、
それぞれのステージでですね、できることというのはかなり変わっているということでございます。
ただ原則として覚えていないといけないのは、
生成AIを利用した場合には開示するのが原則になっているという条件が多いということですね。
そしてもう一つは、
社属の部分から先は原稿を入れられないということが明記されているということでございます。
例えば研究の実施においてはですね、文献検索とかいいよと書いています。
でも、コードとかデータ生成の場合にはですね、条件付きが可能ですと、
つまりデクラレーションをしないといけないということが書いてあったりします。
原稿の作成は構成などはOKですけれども、
そもそも執筆みたいなところはですね、書かないとダメだよと。
例えば1パラグラフ全部AIに書かせましたみたいなところですね、条件付きになるわけでございます。
それからもっと厳しいのは図の生成ですよね。
図の生成自体にAIは不可と。
図の生成の中でコード、データ生成を行うような場合はあると思うんですけど、
その場合にはですね、条件付きの可能ということになるのかなと思うんですけども、
とにもかくにも図の部分、特に画像の部分をAIで触って、
なんか生成しちゃったよみたいなのは本当にアウトになるということでございます。
私、皆さんびっくりした人が多いのかもしれないですけど、
査読ですよね。
皆さんが査読者になって原稿を読んでくれと言われたときにも、
それは不可能なんですね。
唯一自分が書いた原稿のですね、
文法とか英語の遂行のみ条件付きで可能だったりはします。
それから対応とか改定なんですけど、
これもAIは不可ということになっています。
非常になんでこんなになっているのかというのを考えるというのが重要だということでございますね。
他の出しも同様です。
ネイチャーの編集方針とかもありますね。
あと最も緩いのというのは多分AI系の出しですよね。
このユニアネットワークの2025年のポリシーとかいうのはですね、
責任は長者になりますよって、
ここはもう変わらないですけど、
AIDを開示したらですね、
頭脳生成とかは別にAIでやってもいいよ、
できないようになっているわけですね。
なので、
分野によってかなり差があるということでございます。
さっき見た中で、
なんで査読者改定とかに厳しい2つの理由があるのかということなんですけど、
まず機密文字の観点です。
他人の原稿というのは未公開の原稿で、
つまりそれ自体がですね、
十分に機密なわけですね。
それをですね、ポーッと絵に入れて、
第三者に渡っているには大変なことになるということで、
機密保持の観点からですね、
それをしたものは入れてはいけませんよってなっているのがあります。
それからもう一つはですね、評価の主体です。
査読というのは専門家の判断が積み重なることによってきているんですね。
AIがこれいいよ、
これはダメだよというふうに決めているわけではないということです。
つまり、
科学の体系の中に、
総論文を含めるということに対して、
人が責任を取らずにですね、判断していくとなれば、
その体系が崩れるということを意味しているわけですね。
そうした厳しい観点から、
評価の部分とか判断基準の部分というところに、
AIが入ってこれないようにしてあります。
だからこの場合にはですね、自分の言葉の遂行だけしかできなくて、
それからですね、他にも気をつけていけないのが、
入力がですね、学習が使われないとか、
ツールが明記されているようなものというのも、
自分考えた上でですね、
どこに対して使っていくかと、
機密を保ったまま、
禁止でいるところは使わずに、
図なども行わずに、
ということが必要ということでございます。
結構ルールがあるということに驚かれたかと思うのではないでしょうか。
詳細はですね、
ワークの1個目、研究人の部分だったり、
皆さんの所属している学会、
あるいは投稿しようと考える雑誌のですね、
内容をまとめていくことによって、
見ていこうと思います。
ただですね、
普遍的に言うのはこの3つかなと思っていまして、
1つ目はですね、
人間の責任というのが重視されているところがあるよと、
つまり、
砂読の部分もあるし、
あるいはその使った内容のですね、
正確性についても著者の責任だし、
だから砂読で受けていくよと決めるのは、
人の責任だし、
出てきた内容自体を、
これが使ってもいいのかなと考えるのも、
人の責任ということで、
あるということですね。
それから透明性の部分です。
どの段階で何にどのモデルかというのをですね、
書かないといけないということがあったりします。
書かないといけないということは、
皆さん自身がそれらの記録、
あるいはログというのをちゃんと取らないといけないということです。
そして、AI調査になりませんから、
使った道具として記述する必要があります。
そこらへんの原則に立ち返った上でですね、
迷えば安全な方向を取っていただければと思います。
こうしたですね、軸というのは変わらないと思いますので、
常にですね、記録を、記録も残しつつ、
まよったら安全を取りながらですね、
AIの活用というところを進めてもらえればと思います。
で、この問題ですよ。
あなたの研究で、AIの使用を開発しない分ける境界はどこなんでしょうか。
サイエンスより厳しいですか、それとも甘いですか。
あるいは文学のようにですね、
AIを使うのがそもそもかなり難しい領域なんでしょうか。
いろんな問いがあると思いますが、
この分ける境界というのはですね、
この授業の中ではっきりしていこうと思いますので、
皆さん的に関心を持っていただければと思います。
ということで、この動画を終わります。
ご視聴ありがとうございました。